now when we try to order fractions right
I'm gonna put it together with something
that you made a couple of topics ago
which is inequalities I want to know
which ones bigger so that I can write
this is greater than that or this is
less than that depending on which one it
is okay - it's time let's practice it
without diagrams how am I going to get a
common denominator well he but before he
was fired so in general what you can do
is you want to take the top and bottom
here and multiply by the either
denominator watch it with it write it
down with me actually you start with a
corner okay I'm just going to write a
bit about longer line so that I have the
space to do my multiplication I'm gonna
multiply top and bottom it has to be put
by the other denominator which is five
okay
so much might boost by 5 multiplied
let's boost but first I have to do top
and bottom so that it's still equivalent
right so that gives me 5 over 20 okay
great I'll do the same with the other
one but if you like in Reverse I'm gonna
take the two numbers 2 and 5 and I'm
gonna multiply by V R the denominator
which is 4 times 4 times 4 okay which
gives you 8 over 20 so which way should
I do the inequality is a lesser than the
revenue it's 5 trinkets is less than any
20s like so okay so in general sort of
the quick and easy way how did I pick
this 5 here and this for how did I do it
that's usually how'd I do it
I looked at the other denominator did it
that's why I got it from okay yes all
right okay right but that's our first
again yeah
sometimes you can do it quicker than
that and I'm going to go back to what
something you like the whole numbers
okay suppose I gave you these two
fractions instead of a quarter and
two-fifths
I gave you one six and three tenths and
again we're gonna work out okay is it
less than or greater than okay good
we're gonna get to this to this in about
30 seconds one remember all I want is a
common denominator right and did my
interest rate that nice and small if I
can't okay
watch if I want to comment denominator
I'm going to work out the lowest common
multiple of these two numbers lowest
common multiple no 6 and 10 there's more
numbers right we don't need to do a
factor tree for these what's the prime
factorization of C's yep next two
chickens okay what to touch three it is
almost as good as teaching it's the cake
what's the prime factorization of 10
prime factorization two and five isn't
it
therefore what is the lowest common
multiple of 6 and 10 how do you work it
out yeah me too you take the two the 3
and the 5 you don't need to multiply by
the 2 again because you've seen common
get it so it'll be 2 by 3 by 5 which is
1330
so here's what I want to think of I want
to get both of these fractions over now
have a look at 1 over 6 what time
multiply the top and bottom by 2 get
thin I multiply by 5
so times five times five right that's
five over hey good 3o ten what do I
multiply the top and bottom by to get
thirty yep three perfect so I get nine
over thirty okay so you can see this is
a bit quicker the numbers are smaller
and easier to deal with that if I just
pick the other denominator I would have
gotten sixty which is twice as big all
of these numbers would be twice as big I
don't like big numbers like small
numbers they're easier for my head to
handle okay so which way is the
inequality go goes the same way doesn't
it okay
so let me just make sure we've got that
now heads number one the quickest way to
get the common denominator just multiply
by the other denominator bottom you'll
get a number of the work but what's
better is think about this this is more
sophisticated just think of the lowest
common multiple and sometimes that's a
better option okay